the latest on passengers from a carnival
cruise ship who are in quarantine in
seattle after a coveted outbreak
carnival won't say how many travelers
aboard the spirit were infected they
were moved into isolation in local
hotels after the ship docked in seattle
on tuesday this happened just days after
carnival reactivated its entire fleet
which had shut down when the pandemic
began nikki batiste has one of the
passenger's reaction
overwhelmed at sea that's how some
passengers aboard carnival spirit cruise
ship describe staff upon learning of a
covid outbreak i've been on seven
cruises since august
and of course covet is always a concern
darren seifertson was among those who
tested positive i literally stayed in
this room for six days
with no telephone service they wouldn't
answer the phone seifertson says his
travel companion and roommate stayed
with him in the room despite testing
negative and that a list of passengers
names and cabin numbers of those who had
contracted the virus was posted near
elevators the outbreak occurred during
the ship's voyage between miami where it
departed last month and seattle where it
arrived on tuesday upon docking all
infected passengers were moved to local
hotels for isolation carnival refused to
say how many of its approximately 2100
passengers tested positive but insists
travelers were vaccinated and tested
before boarding and in a statement to
cbs news said in part our health and
safety protocols exceed cdc guidelines
and additional measures were implemented
during the voyage but that brings little
comfort to passengers like seifertson
unfortunately this ship was so
unprepared
and so mismanaged
that many of us suffered greatly
for cbs mornings i'm nikki batiste
seven cruises since august that's a lot
of cruising